à chacun son problème à chacun son
affaire à chacun sa façon à chacun sa
manière à chacun sa vie à chacun son
affaire à chacun sa
façon à chacun sa manière à chacun sa
vie à chacun son
[Musique]
affaire tout me m'appelle les mon nom il
m'appelant toutous je suis Rome
d'attribut des Rome
[Musique]
moi je suis le dernier homme à détenir
le grand secret celui qui ouvre les
portes du Paradis celle de l'enfer aussi
je suis zigane et sur ma route j'emporte
avec moi le grand
secret sergan de Rome tu sais bon
c'était une volonté aussi de justement
de toucher les les sédentaires c'est
vrai c'est ça le le plus c'est parce que
personne sait comment qu'on vit il
voient les caravanes puis c'est tout SAV
[Musique]
pas
d'abord il y avait une charrette avec
deux chevaux qui les amener et on allait
avec deux Mercedes les prendre en haut
pour les amener mais directement dans
les caravanes les nôtres ce sont les
nôtres gitan d'Espagne
Tigan d'Ukraine
de Hongrie Manou de France et
d'Allemagne sur la plage prs de ce petit
village on a trouvé la figure de bateau
échoué une belle jeune femme taé dans un
bo noir deviend le symbole
deouv et chaque année à cette même
dateill des sa de la mer les voys quiont
retrouveront pour
rendage quelquun comme ça en curieux ça
peut pas marcher les G VI pas parce qu'à
travers un spectacle les gens
[Musique]
viennent il venit voir un spectacle en
fin de compte il trouvait autre chose il
trouvait aussi une amitié il trouva je
sais
[Musique]
pas
un HME qui s'appelle r c'était Gard de
chasse qui s'occupa bois de maril qui
était race aupart Ilous accill quand on
est rentr sur le terrain les
autorisations il était pas d'accord vou
même pasit fe Ilou rien puis en fin de
compte en nous rencontr plusieurs fois
après cétait lui nous tout ce qu'on
besoin nuit avec nous il a été convcu
100% bonne réussite je su et je porte en
moi l'histoire de mon peuple 1 ans
d'histoire d'un peuple dispersé 1 ans de
voyage pour arriver ici au bout du monde
la fin de la terre est-ce donc ici que
mon chemin s'arrête est-ce ici que mon
histoire prend
fin Gad tu le
[Musique]
bal je dis sédentaire Gad al tu B que
vous soyez que vous ayez la chance
voil pas grand chose mais c'est une
parole recouru chez
[Musique]
nous quand je dis c'est moi sergan le
Rome ça veut dire c'est nous les
derniers et j'espère que on vivra encore
longtemps puisque tu sais c'est ça
double sens cette cette phrase quand je
dis euh est-ce est-ce que bon l'histoire
prend fin est-ce que tu vois ça veut
dire est-ce que on a pu le droit
d'exister ou est-ce qu'on nous donne le
droit d'exister à notre manière de vivre
tu vois la liberté qu'on a toujours eu
et qu'on essaie d'avoir toujours dans la
Bible il est marqué il y a un peuple qui
va Erer sur la terre pendant des
décennies de bah c'est qui c'est nous
peut-être hein
là on est en train de faire des
recherches vu si
vraiment voilà rapport notre
langage parce que les hindou compent
comme nous ils disent de l'eau comme
nous par de l'eau comme nous y a
beaucoup de mot qui se ressemble alors
on sait qu'on vient de l'Inde
[Musique]
mais ouis se prépare on se prépare bah
là je vais brancher un courant là pour
la belle merère parce qu'il y a plus de
courant sinon et après on fait le départ
et on est parti
auange Mar laous ouais tous les ans on
fait les vendanges l'hiver on VI ici
l'été on ça va où ça
partout cœur
partout on voyage un petit peu quand
même he pas beaucoup sur les places tu P
pourquoi tu étais à la préfecture ce
matin car d'entitéé qu'on passe pas
partout Carn tu es obligé d'aller à la
préfecture tu peux pas aller à la mairie
prend une carte d'entité bah oui tu les
fais à la mairie les ces d'identité
c'est fini la préfecture nous à cause
des carnets comme on a des carnets de
circulation ah d'accord renouvelable
c'est renouvelable tous les combien de
temps V carnet 5 ans mais il faut qu'on
va pointer les 3 mois comme moi
maintenant je suis une maman j'ai le
droit à mon carnet tous les 5 ans ah
d'accord je signne tous les un ans tous
les un ans tu sign tous les ans ouais
mais mon il est valable quand même 5 ans
valable 5 et toi 3 mois c'est bon làbas
lou il y a les jeunes qui s'assoi il y a
les jeunes qui s'asso non aussi derrière
il
[Musique]
s'assoit
ce pays riche nous tend les
bras tempécoule au bord du
fleuve
fatigué les voudront s'arrêter
là peuple perdu est sans
histoire ce pays de réjouissance a
disparu dans
mémoir il est encore dans notre
nom
[Musique]
j'étais dans les villes je me rappelle
pas j'étais
gosse j'étais gos j'étais déjà dans
viille avec mes bar j'ai commencé
peut-être à couper j'avais 9 ans si
parce que c'est même pas qui me faisait
travailler mais plaisir tu as vu les
gosses com les gosses tu coupes même là
si on amène des gosses ils vont se
mettre à couper aussi qu'on veut
[Musique]
pas
la va bien tu V comment toi Marc avec
mon
[Musique]
copain la petite monte sur les piquets
je crie mais elle m'écoute
pas
ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens savent que on n pas les patrons
on n pas les chefs mais c'est nous les
plus vieux et en fait ça se fait
automatiquement 4 là parce que ça va
chauffer dans les
liges ça va tout bien c'est bien tu vois
on n pas besoin d'être là pour leur
rappeler que c'est nous les plus vieux
en
fait c coup allez dit que vous aimz
votre patron celui qui porte en fait
celui qui pi le
groupe tu vois comme Bou et mon fils par
exemple les de porteurs c'est eu qui
gè en fait il pr il prennent directement
comment ça
marche jeis pasas vu pas sur c'est pas
c'est qu'il font naturellement il les
autes comment qu' font il font
pareil c'est bien comme ça ou quoi TR
que c'est
bien quand quelquun se sent libre de
faire en fait qu' s pas
touours e
entrepr nimporte il se s pas BRI tu
[Musique]
sais
jeend car
pouriillous crois uneand pays
[Musique]
dans sommes aussi pauvres que vous et
plus AFF encore laissous aider au MO éch
donnez-nous à manger et le soir nous
jouons pour vous de la
musique nous donons amis une fête comme
nous avons pas donné depuis longtemps il
débouche pour l'occasion quelques
bouteilles d'une boisson CLA comme de
l'au mais qui brle la bouche comme une
braise qu'on
[Musique]
mangeod
VOD qui fait tourner la tête
[Musique]
me mettait devant la charette assis et
me disait vas-y va che va prendre les va
demander s V les ciseaux les
couteaux je couteau ciseau les gens
ramené leur couteau le ciseau et je les
a guuisé avec la
[__] et après mon père il me fait
écoute maintenant tu vas prendre le
décapage et le ramonage prendre un
carcher et puis ramonnage prendre des
grandes baguettes les visser les unes
sur les autres avec le truc si RAM
monage et tu appuyé il faut voir j'étais
noir comme un caillou hein tu vois et
j'ai fait les fleurs aussi chin les
fleurs tu prendre des roses acheter des
paquets de roses moi je fais ça tac tac
tac tac les mettre dans un machin en
plastique allez hop là et puis alleer
les marmites aussi j'ai fait pas de
problème après j'ai tendu les pelouses
tuas vu tu veux te payer des habits me
dit tu veux des chaussures parce que je
pleurer pour des chaussures les
chaussures sont trouées parce que
j'allais j'étais à l'école mais pendant
un an l'école bien paraître bien propre
ça fait que je pleurais mes chaussures
sont craqu tu veux les chaussures va
travailler alors qu'est-ce que je
faisais moi j'ais de l'avant des fois je
travaille même le samedi le dimanche moi
j' pas un jour de repos vois je tout ça
à 5h du matin je préparis tous mes
petites affaires pour alleriner pour
aller travailler je travaillais jusqu'à
temps que j'avais la somme exacte pour
fa une petite de
chaussure arrête pas
je là de
[Musique]
l' pour eux c'est pas Coutu tu verrez la
Champagne sans vendance
les vendant
ch
ou on se débrouille comme on peut on est
pas
faignant voir dans les
vendanges
[Musique]
CP
arr couper ça ser pas fini à mi je l'ai
dit ils étaient tous en train de
remonter tout le monde
attendait coup j'éis pas content moi je
m'en fous moi je dis moi je suis à
l'heure ou al ça fini à midi ou mid moi
je m'en
fous bon c'est
bon ai parce que dès qu'il y a quelque
chose c'est c'est pas les autres qui
vont prendre c'est moi qui va prendre si
M s'avance plus dans les Lig c'est moi
qui va
prendre parce que c'est moi qui m'occupe
des des couop
ouais c'éit normal bah ouais c'est
normal je le sais très bien que c'est
c'est
normal problème de toute façon je do le
respect des vieux j'ai rien à
dire dit quelque
chose alors tu as fait les venduss j'ai
vend aussi AR qui m'a piqué la main ou
j'avais la main gonflé comme ça ah ou
c'est important ça j'amais eu comme ça
la main comme ça
gonfl mais moi je suis
mortout des années 60
papa la caravane devant la porte de la
vieille retraité
[Musique]
rrait ici tout
pourrait
disparaître il ne faut pas nous
résigner même si les loups sont ns
maîtres il faudra
toujours
espérer si nos enfants voyent
Ren tous les esprits dans la
fumée alors il serai reconnaître des
champs
d'amour de
liberté un jour il vous faudra remettre
êre au coup du jour la
vérité que puissent enfin les ROM
naître plus au vent de
votre
[Musique]
société nous
t pareil
puis avant on pouvait plus travailler
comme on faisait couteau ciseau ramage
descage
maintenant quand on se présente chez les
gens oui bonjour madame petite rose
c'est bientôt ça pas les
truc on a besoin de plus personne parce
qu'il y a 18 personnes là qui demandent
si on cherche pas du travail S a
pas sinon tu connais personne qui cherch
de des vendangeurs non hein tu vois
personne ça va se terminer
partout non monsieur pas de chance c'est
pas grave
allez vous remercie bien on vous
remercie bien au
revoir vous employez souvent des g pour
la jamais jamais non non qui vous
ouvriez vous on a des gens à l'heure ah
ouou on a fini 7 jours nousop VOP vite
trop vite on cherch en 15
jours 7 jours céit B jourséit en plus il
a tout le
temps vraiment désolé non c'est la fin
c'est la fin maintenant c'est terminé
pas la
d'inister
rienn prochaine oui l'année
[Musique]
prochaine
ou la
[Musique]
porte 12 12 enants commentit
pour
combien
4 le 4e 5 5e ou 5e je suis
5 5e en France
[Musique]
5è ils sont tous en caravane
carav toi aussi tu es en caravane oui je
suis en caravane
aussi tranquille gens de
voyage Caravan j'habite làe en face on
seit pas hein ah non si on a pas Caravan
on peut pas
vivre
ta et c'est qui le
chef la famille à
moi tout le monde comment que ça marche
mais c'est toujours les les garçons en
général chez nous la femme a beaucoup à
dire quand elle est toute seule avec le
mari mais quand il y a du monde alors là
c'est fini c'est l'homme qui dit tout
par exemple le soir il dit par exemple
le soir il dit je vais te taper le soir
on rentre et vont pas nous taper s'ils
sont pas contents on leur claque les
marm si j'ai quelque chose à dire je le
dis si mon a quelque chose à dire dis il
disens toujours comme ça mais tap
pas pour ça que nous mariage tient plus
longtemps préfère être groupé que
séparé il y a com comme ma sœur je la
vois tous les jours malgré qu'elle est
mariée mon frère je le vois tous les
jours ma mère pareil vu qu'elle s'est
mis en camp à côté il y a encore ma mère
ma
tante il
a je pas chanter rien du tout moi on va
toujours
ensemble
tjours on vient de s mararer la merde
[Musique]
des
mot si moi vous pas
voil Dr bien et sans méfiance Bou les BR
avec
anésix le CI toujours plus haut par
flamencofiant les
hommes
[Musique]
dan
tous ces peuples rencontrés tellement
semblables pourtant et qui se font la
guerre parfois au nom d'un dieu imposé
aux uns par les autres souvent au nom
d'une terre revendiqué par les uns et
les
autres comment la Terre peut-elle
appartenir à l'un plutôt qu'à
l'autre ça nous avons du mal à le
comprendre
અલવાી ંાી રંગી રંગલા અલવાી ડાી રંગી
રંગલા હલવાી
ાી રંી રંગ બયા
ી રી રંગ બ રં બયા ી રંગ બયા આદમી પપણ આયા
આદમી પપણ આયા
રી ર
[Musique]
ainsi les Romes de l'IND lointaine qui
ont suivi sergan deviennent
bohémien grâce à leurs papiers ils vont
parcourir
[Musique]
l'Europe
depuis 69 ça a changé sous de Gaulle
c'est une qui sortie pendant de Gaulle
c'était un carnet alors à ce momentlà cé
encore plus compliqué parce que c'était
un gros carnet et tu le signais à
l'arrivée dans la commune quand tu es
arrivais dans une commune si tu restais
8 10 jours quand tu repartais tu
resignais le départ et quand tu roulais
sur la route s'il y avait si tu faisais
100 km mettons s'il y avait trois ou
quatre cantons sur sur la route
gendarmerie tu étais obligé de t'arrêter
et de signer à vite passage en passant
alors s'il en avait 4 C comme ça bah tu
mettais je sais pas combien d'heures
pour arriver pour faire les 100
km à partir de 16
ans à partir de 16 ans ils sont obligés
de le
prendre ah ben à l'étranger je suis
obligé de prendre une carte d'identité
qui va avec le
carnet je j'ai au Passeport aussi mais
toujours pareil toujours avec le avec en
disant que j'ai le Carné
quoi les communes qui seront retenu dans
le schéma départemental pour créer des
aires d'accueil auront une obligation de
les créer dans un délai de 2 ans il est
prévu que pour créer quelques 25000
places l'état apportera
1ard750 millions et pour le
fonctionnement des aires d'accueil 30000
places à 10000 francs 300 millions par
an mais de manière P c'estàdire pendant
de très nombreuses
années c'est
mieux comme ça voilà je jamaisi non mais
lui aussi c'est quand même un peu je
untit pe c'est un petit peu
lire
Pneau jamais à l'école mais
j'essaie rassembler tous mes mots sur un
panneau J
jamais vu bouteillage comme ça même cam
rentrprit esprit la foncé rentr derrière
ce que je souhaite c'est que cette loi
après une période où il y a eu un
développement des
tensions parce qu'il y avait un manque
de place aujourd'hui on considère qu'il
y a 5000 places et quand on essaie de
chiffrer le nombre de caravanes qui
roulent personne n'arrive à moins de
30000 donc il y a un déficit
colossal contrôler toi ouais il a la
tête cour
lui donc ce déficit est à l'origine de
tension c'est-à-dire que les gens du
voyage qui savent qu'il y a pas de
terrain pour les accueillir se sentent
contraints à des occupations illégales
et donc si l'occupation est illégale ils
ont bien vite compris que s'il venaent à
deux ou trois caravanes la première
brigade de gendarmesis réunissait assez
d'hommes pour les faire partir alors que
s'ils viennent à 50 ou 60 caravanes il
faut escadron tu n'as pas bien compris
crapo ça fait des jours que nous vous
suivons que nous vous observons
boniron un cavalier
musicien ce qui sur mes terr est à moi
tu as eu l'impudance detit père ma foi
voilà une bonne poignée d'esclave trouvé
à bon
marché quelques
chariot quelques chevaux en bon état
tout est moi ici vous êtes à
[Musique]
moi petit à petit il y a beaucoup de
gens du voyage qui vivent cette
précarité d'être constamment présent
temporairement mais que dans
l'affrontement il faut sortir de ce
schéma c'est pas
possible
les
TR et donc les communes ont tout intérêt
à se dépêcher parce que ce taux
privilégié de financement n'est pas
garanti au-delà du délai des 2 ans
pendant lesquels court l'obligation du
moment qu'il y a un terrain voir ça se
fait dans chaque commune que où il y a
un terrain vraiment je parle de ceux qui
restent sur place je parle pas des
terrains de passage puisque ça c'est
chose c'est gens qui passent et qui
continuent et quand il y a un terrain je
vois que de plus en plus il y a des
petites associations qui se forment sur
ce terrain et qui se font reconnaître
comme un quartier de la commune et qui
participe à tout ce que qui se fait sur
la commune less noust
[Musique]
corrompusous
Lech du voyage on voit vraiment la
différence on voit que s'il y a des lois
ils sont pas appliqué pour les gens du
voyage
il y a vraiment c'est noir et
blanc si on ne pose pas ça en principe
dire que la République veut veut
atteindre des objectifs de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité serait quelque
part démenti dans les fêes s' y a une
constitution qui existe qui dit des
choses et puis qui sont pas
appliqué
alors à quoi qu' sert cette
constitution je vois pas qu'est-ce qu'on
peut détériorer sur un emplacement quand
c'est du béton ou du ma
je sais pas si vous avez vu les
toilettes sur le terrain ben c'est
toujours en béton ça se casse pas comme
ça c'est toujours tout simple il y a
même pas de chasse d'eau et bien pour
l'instant c'est un terrain provisoire
malheureusement qui risque de durer
parce que je je me méfie toujours des
terrains provisoires on narrive pas à
mettre un tu montres
viens s'appelle lolit mais vraiment
c'est la guuse c'est la guuse ouais la
méchante quoi essaie de la mettre à
l'école là il reste av pr une semaine et
la prof après il a plus voulu apprendre
parce qu'il était toujours dans son coin
toujours à part comme il l'é de elle a
plus voulu
aller c'est pas méchant parce qu'il faut
pas qu'il fa les différences nous on les
met dedans justement c'est pour qu'il
seroupe avec les autres jeunes faut pas
qu'il a de différence de GO pas qu'il
c'est gitant c'est un français non ch
voilà j'ai vu le quand j'étaisir un
psychologue je ouais un psychologue un
pyomoteur là expliqu avec ouais mais dit
il faut la frapper de tant en temps je
attendis c'est pas évident de frapper un
gosse comme ça he non de dire mant pour
un truc quelque chose par force quand il
fait des des ses colères de lui dire non
quoi mettre une claque sur le cul de
dire non tu peux pas faire ça mais bon
pour moi c'est pas évident je l'ai
jamais fait B c'est vrai pour quelqu'un
qui l' habitué dire tiens non tu as pas
le droit pour une bon c'est pas méchant
qu'elle il me l'a jamais fait alors
c'est pour ça que pour l'autre je vois
pas l'utilité de lui mettre une peti car
par depuis 5 ans elle ve par is ben le
Batton tu lui chêes sinon je te mets une
cque sous le cul tu connais pas tu
connais pas parler tu vas chanter
psychologue non on va prendre à
allerécrire
VI chez
nous dans les
[Musique]
camions qui
m'appelle voilà lesour la
fon normalement faudrait une fontaine
spéciale qu'on pluse mettre un grand
Tyon pour arroser les caravanes quelque
fois on vient à côté de la fontaine on
met les
caravanes on met les caravanes
ici pour les laver c'est très fatiguant
on prend des grands bidons là aller
retour très lourd les grands bidons hein
ben
obligé c'est pas évident hein évidemment
bon fa jouer
je prends ma guitare tu viens
hein ça commencer comme ça il y avait tu
sais la fête de la musique au départ
donc je dis voilà quand même ça fait à
pe pr 400 personnes avec les enfants on
a un quartier de vavdasque je vais aller
trouver la mairie et là-bas je tombe sur
des personnes qui sont formidables qui
qui m'écoutent ah oui ça serait bien que
vous feriez ça tu vois ils sont
partant je B tiens ça serait bien aussi
qu'on fait le ftival de la danse si tu
crois que tu peux peux le faire qui me
fait essaye mais je voudrais voir
fais-moi un comment on dit ça un
programme oui un programme moi je pas le
faire moi si tu veux je te le dis et tu
le marques quand mêmean qui s'est mis à
la guitare qui joue de la guitare j'ai
mon fils bon ben bientôt si ça marche il
va être quand même professeur de danse
zigan attention zigane traditionnelle la
danse il a déjà fait sur le ça a marché
donc tu vois ça donne quand même des
idées tout
[Musique]
ça
ore
donc ça nous encourage on
[Musique]
continue700â ça tu vois
pas
on est arrivé à 4000
10000 puis maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que vra surtout c'est que des choses
comme ça pourrai se propager au plan
national parce que ça serait bien j'ai
pris beaucoup de contact avec DEES
Titans qui qui me demandent comment vous
faites comment vous faites le bal et qui
aimerit bien le faire aussi dans
d'autres régions et c'est vrai que pour
les autres régions faut qu'il trouve
aussi des gens à l'écoute parce que les
toutes les communes sont pas à l'écoute
des gens du voyage là on a eu la chance
quand même à villed faut dire la vérité
de trouver des des interlocuteurs qui
nous
écouter je voudrais qu'il me donne quand
même des moyens parce que j'ai pas les
moyens de si j'ai les moyens mais pas
assez tu vois c'est très dur on les fait
avec des bouts de
ficelle heureusement que je me
débrouille avec les groupes parceut les
groupes c'est très cher j'arrive à les
prendre moins
cher
maintenant il y a des amitiés qui se et
puis les gens quand ils viennent au
balzigan dans toutes les manifestations
culturelles qu'on fait je suis sûr que
la plupart repartent avec des autres
idées si plus l'idée du voleur de poule
le Gitan marur et puis tout maintenant
il sa
que comme dans toutes les ennemies il y
a peut-être 5 % de délinquant pas plus
comme dans toutes les les
[Musique]
peuples le gars il est on le connaissait
pas il restait dans le Midi et puis bon
il av pris cette fill là et puis le père
était pas d'accord il savait même pas sa
fille il était parti il a vu de loin sur
la route il c'est ma fille là-bas mais
l'homme é déjà était malade il était
pris par les n tout ça alors donc il
nous appelé pour arranger les affaires
comme ça alors je dis non norement c'est
chez nous vous savez c'est on demande
une fille au mariage et si une fille
vous la prenez comme ça vous allez vous
êtes obligé de
payer
moi je expliqu en Romanis lui comprenait
pas disait oui oui oui oui oui je cro
qu'il a comprisand 50000 franc lu
compris 5000
fr
vou pour nous voleurs de
fill on fait la demande au mariage tu
comprends on fait un
mariage en
fait c'est pour rassembler la famille
même étranger tout ça et vant on n pas
[Musique]
d'habitation alors on toujours les G au
église on dit g mariage comme là par
exemple comme moi je suis en famille on
dit pas Gouch on dit
Kibo moi je suis à tout mon Kibo mon
Kibo c'est dire
mon je suis avec
mon après religion à nous à N parce
qu'on est évangél on n pas le droit la
femme on pas le uneutre femme de se
marier avec elle comprend sele
[Musique]
fem le moment de
la je veux rien
[Musique]
moi
demandé un tarif que les plus chez nous
homes de discé du prix pour un tarif Mo
cher on l' suivi carav
4out de la 4 table la demande on a la
[Musique]
parole
SP pas ils sont à vie jusqu la
mort là c'est la marié qu'on VO en
regardant le
film elle est naturelle réellement cher
en il est mieux il est mieux Natur
heureuse maisant n'est
[Musique]
pas
c'est une jeune fille c'est une
[Musique]
fleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il il coûte cher là 2 secondes
il a mis 1000
francs mais pour pas qu'ils oublient
quand ils vont avoir des gosses la
parole qui a été dit pour leur parents
elle va être dit pour leurs enfants et
ce sera ainsi de suite voilà la parole
par exemple elle va traverser tout un
une famille tout un
monde qu ça a été dit ça ça se raconte
du bouch
moi que je suis l'homme de loi je suis
plus âgé je te sépare de ta femme et
tout des gosses que j'ai rien à voir de
ta famille je suis pas tes beaux parents
je suis pas ton père je suis pas ton
frère je suis seulement un homme de loi
avec ma parole je te sépare de ta femme
et tes enfants pourquoi parce qu'il y a
de jours en arrière je t'ai vu en boîte
mettons avec une autre
[Musique]
femme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pe lui dire on lui obligé caravane sa
voiture et se rrouver un jour à l'utre
caravanrouve à la si tu prends les
conditions ce soit sur un mariage ce
soit
sur ça veut dire sur un
tribunal pour n'importe quoi si tu
respectes pas ta parole ils sont en
droit t'attaquer et te faire
[Musique]
payer
av il rien du tout du tout iler son
écras
carrment pay
pas mil de la frontière de
[Musique]
l'indppé pour celui qui voulait le plus
de pays
possibletit fa écras par le
grand
[Musique]
on peut dire aussi d'un pays que é a eu
un cataclisme et puis que notre
peup et puis on s'est retrouvé sur les
routes et puis du coup ben de voyage en
voyage on a trouvé ça meilleur et puis
on a resté à
voyager alors il y a des légendes comme
ça tu veux
l tu sais avec l' a disparu on est les
derniers
ATL nelle
[Musique]
création
લે વા
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
મા સારેગી એન્ડ સિંગર ઉસ્તાદ બરકત ખાન
લંગા
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
ચલદગો
on a résisté c'est pendant la guerre bon
les C de concentration les camp de la
mort ils ont essayé aussi de
nouséteindre la
rnie comme pour les juifs ils ont pas
réussi quand même heureusement qume ont
pu sortir DEAMP recommencé une
vie regarde les pays de l'Est il ont
sédentarisé par force ils étaient
obligés de rester dans les maisons tuas
vu dans des maisons cabane qui il leur
empêch de parler romanes le empêch de de
s'habiller longue et ben je vois que
depuis que les frontières sont ouvertes
ben il recommenc à voyager il a plein
qui viennent en
[Musique]
France
[Applaudissements]
le temps que je vais à la porte trop
tard puis je descends qu'est-ce qui se
passe faut pas faut partir
oui puis je me retourne je vois la porte
et une porte ça vaut 3500 pasigol
quandme vous voyez pas ce que vous avez
fait qu'est-ce qu'on a fait tu as vu
énervé le c'est un AD chef on na rien
fait nous ben j sais vous avez fait des
bosses dans ma
caravane moi j'ai frappé comme ça il
retape et on me refait encore deux
bosses trois bosses tu com j'ai quand
même vous voz bien ce que vous faites et
puis il y a l'huissier de jusce Luissier
justice tu as vu c'est quand même
assmenté monsieur quand même vous voyez
bien que qu'il fait là quand même il
fera quand même dans ma caravane il fait
des bosses
là non moi je moi j'ai j'ai vu qu'ils
étaient déj les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bosses camé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
C
va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
B
oup chance amour c'est la fête des
G
bonhe
[Musique]
bonheouour
je va dire la formule c'est pourquoi au
nom du Président de la République des
pouvoirs qui n sont conférés je vous
fais chevalier la Légion
[Applaudissements]
d'Honneur une
deè
les maisons d'éducation de la Légion
d'honneur qui sont ouvertes aux filles
peties filles et arrière petite fill de
légionnaires et de membres de l'Ordre
National du Mérite pour assurer leur
éducation dans l'amour de la patrie et
de la
liberté surtout une école pour apprendre
déjà à lire et écrire ça serait déjà pas
mal tu sais ma petite fille Éolia on l'a
mis au commencement quand on est arrivé
là elle est la première de sa classe
voilà pour une mais l'autre elle était
plus belle
rougeir sans le savoir je commence à
[Musique]
comprendre
Mar
ok on faire toujours une musiqueane
pours amis français la républque
française et souite le bienvenue à tout
le
[Musique]
monde